you
[Music]
every little thing you think that's mean
every little thing exactly every little
thing that's feeding your green or a
bear that you decide about hello
everybody welcome to the minimalists
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn just a
quick intro for this one we just
finished this web series it's called
making minimalism when I say we I really
mean our talented director matthew Vella
he he sat down and did this five episode
series and then did a sixth episode you
can find all of those on our YouTube
channel over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and the sixth episode was
actually a Q&A we recorded out in
Portland Maine a few weeks ago while we
were on tour we sat down with Matthew
Vella he had some questions from our
audience some YouTube comments and
different questions from social media
and all three of us were on camera but
this is going to be the audio version of
that so if you've already seen it you
can skip this one but if you haven't
seen it yet and you just want to hear
the audio while you're driving or
working out or or doing the laundry like
that's usually when I listen to podcasts
I'm I'm folding some laundry at some
point in time before I'm doing physical
therapy something like that anyway
here's the audio from that we had some
really good questions we had some good
dialogue with Matt if you haven't
checked out the whole making minimalism
series I would encourage you to do it it
was really a behind-the-scenes look on
how we made that documentary how it went
from having this just having this idea
back in 2013 to three years later having
out on Netflix and millions of people
watching it we also did a theatrical
release and a bunch of other stuff and
he really breaks it down the the
soup-to-nuts approach of how to make a
documentary and also do it on a
minimalist budget with minimalist
equipment and in really just a vision
and that really propelled us throughout
the whole thing speaking of being on
tour were also on the road right now
you want to come see us on tool we're
headed to a city near you or actually
we're probably headed to your city if
not we'll be at a city pretty close to
wherever you are you can go to les is
now calm we just announced the second
leg of the tour so we're going to be in
San Diego Los Angeles actually I think
Los Angeles has already sold out
San Francisco Indianapolis Cincinnati
Columbus and Cleveland that's the end of
the first leg of the tour but then in
the back half of 2017 we're headed to
Toronto Ottawa Montreal Vancouver
Calgary Edmonton Philadelphia Manhattan
Brooklyn Salt Lake City Denver Phoenix
Austin Dallas Houston Nashville
Washington DC atlanta Tampa Detroit and
Milwaukee so come on out say hi grab a
free hug Ryan and I are going to give a
talk about minimalism we will record a
live version of our podcast as well I
hope you enjoy this Q&A session we had
with Matt dia Vela and by the way met
have some other really great projects
going on some great video projects and
he has a wonderful podcast as well
called the ground up podcast if you're
looking for other podcasts to listen to
you can check out the ground-up podcast
over at Matt Diavel accom it's on itunes
or wherever else you get your podcast
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well alright I hope you enjoy
this conversation about making
minimalism oh and one other thing if you
want to support our podcast we just
started a patreon account let's go to
patreon.com/scishow notes as well we're
trying to build a new film studio so we
can do a lot more video work and also
higher quality audio work we want to
bring in some special guests and do some
video essay some live streams some mini
documentaries interviews and much much
more
that money goes to me or Ryan it goes to
helping us build a audio and video
studio also paying our producer podcast
Shawn paying him a full-time living wage
and then any additional funds we have if
we have anything left over we'll make
sure we donate that to charity so if you
would go ahead and hop on over to
patreon comm slash the minimalists and
you can support us on a per episode
basis we really do appreciate that
support thank you to our first 500 or so
patrons we're looking forward to many
more if we can get to 5,000 patrons
we'll have enough money to hire a
full-time filmmaker so that we can we
can produce a lot more meaningful video
content if you can't support us
financially I totally understand you can
also support us by leaving a review on
Apple podcasts those reviews help us
reach a lot more people alright y'all
enjoy the show wait are we supposed to
look at the camera we can look at the
camera yeah it's going to be a back and
forth it's going to be very informal
okay I'm going to edit it to make it
look really smart I'm not going to see
ya
[Music]
this is episode six and with me I have
the minimal hello everyone Joshua fields
Melbourne I'm not actually used to
seeing that without a camera so I I'm I
usually want to avoid looking directly
at him cuz I was just a camera up to it
yeah the most your life is spent
ignoring me perfect so I have some
questions here from YouTube people have
been asking about the series Arielle I
would like to ask if it was hard at one
point to put a lot of money and time
into a project without knowing if it was
going to work we split the cost so it
wasn't just all on Josh and I wasn't
just all on you it wasn't just all
inspired media so Josh and I were
certainly prepared because we have been
saving over the last several years since
we since we started the minimalists comm
you know there's a little bank account
we have that we we put money into to
invest into our business at the end of
the day like I knew Josh and I had
enough of an audience who wanted a
documentary like this so bad that I was
pretty confident and like there was no
business model behind it but my gut my
gut told me that we would at least make
at least break even yeah and we were
willing though to lose that investment
and lose the money and at the end of day
we would have lost everything
yeah the initial like production like
ryan said we we started with zero we
didn't we didn't go into a saying all
right here's our budget for this film i
think that would have been scary like if
we would have said hey let's spend a
quarter million dollars to make a
documentary right because then all of a
sudden the pressure is like here it is
you could say let's split 30 grand
between six people yeah yeah we had the
opposite pressure was like and it's a
different kind of pressure it seems less
scary to me but more of a challenge how
do you make a documentary for
functionally zero dollars at first air
is close to zero dollars as possible and
then of course there would be call
setting once you get to a point where
you feel great about the film that's
really where the calls came in I felt
like I don't know if you agree or not
but like if we had a terrible film we
felt shitty about it we're not gonna be
like all right let's go all for color
grading now yeah hey let me back let's
pay someone to make some music
were you scared I wasn't and in terms of
the finances I was also at a point I
mean I graduate college with one hundred
and ten thousand dollars in student loan
debt and have bought a brand-new car so
at that time I wouldn't have been able
to do it because I needed to make money
I needed to actually have some savings
but I had gotten to a point that when
you guys came and said hey let's make
this documentary it was kind of the
perfect time for me because I was just
about to pay off all of my debt but I
had enough savings that I was like
alright I can do this I could like
sacrifice two three months here and
there to get started and like you said
getting started costs essentially
nothing if I have all the gear and all
work I mean what did we spend like a
thousand dollars on flights and split
between six people it yeah we stayed in
the same hotel like Ryan and I were on
that tour so we stayed in the same hotel
rooms and like we'd share a bed again
readers home or keep Airbnb
every once in a while be honest no man I
wasn't scared Matt because it was
because of you like I wasn't scared you
you came out to New York and he filmed
that book trailer and then you sent us
the book trailer and I was like oh my
and you just had that little camera it
was just like such a look like a guy
from Walmart yeah exactly like it really
did look like it to me
and you're like Mike and it's up and
stuff and you get this little camera you
can somewhat as well but I'm like I have
no idea this is going to turn out but
you just wanted to work on it as a
passion project but when you sent that
to its the final product it was so
amazing that I knew that if you did come
on the road with us like I had a lot of
faith that you would be able to create
something beautiful like I didn't very
expected to make anything off the movie
or beyond that flick surf or whatever
maybe but I was willing to take the
chance and felt confident that we would
at least break even on the film due to
that do that trailer like I knew you
would create something beautiful by the
way it took a long time to even break
even and if anything that was a little
bit of a scary part because I mean there
were some failures in there for sure I
mean for me we did it's weird because it
was a by most measures it was a wildly
successful theatrical release it was
number one in d-doc opening for any
independent film of 2016 or any any
independent documentary I should say not
any independent film any independent
documentary
and that sounds great but then you
realize that well the theater instantly
gets fifty three percent and distributor
takes half of what's left and all by the
way there are taxes and feed and really
weird holiday wood math that all of a
sudden you get to a point where it never
understood the term Hollywood math until
going down this road yeah yeah it
actually we we hadn't broken even even
after having the such a successful
release and debut and having a tour even
after the theatrical release it still
hadn't broken even it it took it took
till we get we got to the online release
so we're even able to recoup the full
amount of money if anything was scary
was that part where it was like okay
we've gone down this path and it has
been lucrative in terms of revenue but
the overall amount of money that we're
using to pay back the debt on this film
I say dead it's our own money or I
paying ourselves back you know that it
we did not take one loan out for this no
no no nor would I have ever I mean
that's a good as dead and borrow like
fifty yeah yeah not true not for the
record I'm joking Andy asks I realized
that minimalism is about getting rid of
stuff you don't need but what about
minimizing the things you do I'm always
over booked and I feel like I can never
catch a breath what do you do then Andy
Andy all those boulders that you have on
your back that you're carrying you pick
them up you can put whatever Boulder you
want down you have to say no to as many
things as possible so you could say yes
to so much more that's what I would tell
Andy we do it I mean it's in I don't
know Andy's exact situation but when I
was like that when I see most people who
were like that they've done it to
themselves and they can totally undo it
themselves Elyse has a question here I
was just wondering how if at all have
all of your lives changed
making the film and what can we do as a
society to further promote this message
tells eruptions how is my life changed
you actually it's changed a lot and it's
really it's more so my choices that I've
made after releasing the film because
for me it was the hardest most most
difficult thing I've worked on it was
such a big project but having done it
and gone through it I realized that
creating original content which is so
much more fulfilling than doing client
work which is all I had done before you
had cook filling client work I'm sure at
least more fulfilling than others right
yeah I think to say it wasn't fulfilling
would be wrong but I think there was a
kind of fulfillment and a kind of
creative output that I could put on an
original project that I would never be
able to do in a client work at the end
of the day when I when I do a client
project there could be 1015 revisions
that skews it away from my direction as
to where it's an original project while
collaborating there's really no such
thing as a revision it's like being a
CPA you you certainly have the intellect
ergo be a certified public accountant
but are you really going to put in the
extra hours to make sure someone else's
taxes get done no it it's not what
you're passionate about I think it's the
same thing with virtually anything
you're doing luckily Ryan and I have a
CPA who's passionate about accounting
and it's the only person I've ever met
who's actually into that there was
another question there that Oh how's
your lives how have your lives changed
you can't go outside anymore well it was
funny man we were in Boston yesterday
we're in Boston yesterday right around
the venue it was Chinatown in Boston and
I'm walking around and it was the first
time where I knew that no one would
recognize me over the last you know six
months or whatever it's been I've found
that the more and more I go out it'll be
you know a dozen times a day I mean
we're not like we're not celebrities you
know Brad pig is recognized by every
single person he runs into I can't even
imagine what that kind of universe is
like ours is a different kind of weird
universe where one out of a hundred
people recognize you but you're one out
of fifty or or maybe one out of 100 come
up and say hi and one out
want to recognize who you are and then
your and so I found the good side of
that is actually making sure that my
actions are congruent with the best
person I want to be because I know that
no matter what I'm in a weird way always
being sort of extra a little pitch more
scrutinized the only way my life is
changes I get recognized more I mean
other than that it's you know we don't
have the odds now although you know
minimalism part two maybe after that
will have minimum or C odds yeah there's
a question in here that will get through
what was the second part of that
question ever good at what it was more
about the society so welcome and how do
I get for the promotion so if anyone out
there wants to promote this message they
just need to tell their friends and
family about I mean that is the best way
to spread anything I mean when you go to
a coffee shop and it's amazing what do
you do you go tell your friend about it
if you have an amazing experience with
with a company then what do you do you
tell your friends and family but you put
it on Facebook you put on social media
so I would just encourage people to do
the same thing that they do with other
things that they find value and this is
from Roger what was the most challenging
thing about making this film and if you
were to do it again what would you do
differently the only thing that I would
do differently is I think Josh would
agree with this is a tour we went on in
2014 we just learned a lot of lessons
like don't reserved a room for 70 in
Indianapolis because 500 people might
show up to see you and you might have to
turn away 430 people what a horrible
experience now luckily that to take that
did happen in Indianapolis but luckily
there was a theater across the street
that the bookstore owner had a
relationship with and we just happen to
like call inaudible and move everything
over so it just worked out on the fly I
feel like yes there are always be
problems we'll never have a perfect tour
stop but the problems get better over
time like that problem last night it was
like hey there's going to be a thousand
or 1,100 people here in Boston at this
huge gorgeous theater and we've got to
talk and they're really excited to see
us and then
having a video issue whereas like with
our first tour was like I remember
actually in the documentary we showed up
in Vegas man
we rented a venue and no one was at the
venue that that's a much bigger broad
can you imagine if we were at the Wilbur
theater last night in Boston and no one
was at the venue close yeah
nightmare yeah so better problem yeah I
got one more question and this is a
question from a lot of people and they
keep asking what's next are you working
on anything new is there is a minimalism
v2 or is there another film project that
we're working on yeah I don't know how
you typically answer that question yeah
I mean I'll tell you how I answered it
last night but it actually wasn't a
question when we were we were doing the
QA with the crowd we were recording a
live podcast and I was just thanking you
and Paige and Conrad for for being there
at the event and what I told the the
people there we're recording this right
now we recorded the QA record a bunch of
other stuff that go along with it and
I'm not sure what exactly is going to
come out of it but it worked out really
well last time we weren't sure what
exactly was going to come out of so are
we working on something yes what is it
it's a bit nebulous right now and that
excites me because we get to develop
what the the shape of that thing is we
get to figure out where we're going from
here and and that part can be a little
scary because no one is going to drag us
in that direction we have to we have to
keep walking in that direction ourselves
well I just remember when you left with
you know two terabytes of footage a
thousand hours of footage or whatever
from the tour I just remember thinking
like 950 hours of Sonic right oh yeah
head time why did it's changing now man
we shot for like five days and we
already have one terabyte us but it but
what you do is you're able to boil it
down to bring out the awesome content
that's in that like I feel like you're
going to be able to do the same thing
with this footage so like I hope there
is a series that comes or you know a
special or something that comes out of
out of all this a video video video
graffia my saying that right my my so my
parents call me at videographer doesn't
matter
GameSalad okay III remember I was dating
someone once and she refer to me as a
blogger uh yeah every member of the
traveling book salesman oh yeah what it
felt like that sometimes man but yeah I
mean I'm an author and that's not even
the title and now I'm just I'm
comfortable whatever you want to call me
here yeah a blogger like [ __ ] what does
it matter man I mean Matt is such a
talented filmmaker and the the
documentary that you made I mean that
you ended up just you're not shaping
this thing man and I'll tell you you can
call you whatever someone call you
whatever they want they can't take away
the fact that like that is your first
feature-length film yeah holy [ __ ] man
yeah it's just so great man what I think
is actually great is that it's it's the
fact that we're doing this this little
Q&A here about minimalism as we are
literally starting a new project and we
don't know what that project is going to
be now right but I'm excited like
honestly Disney the past four days are
pretty awesome I think we got some
killer oh and then I know I know you
didn't I've only seen like this tiny
little speck of it like I saw like the
little keyhole view into your world man
and I'm already excited about it I can't
wait a minute and that does it for
making minimalism thank you so much for
watching you got any value from it you
can subscribe to this channel for more
videos I'm going to be creating a lot of
behind the scenes content for new
projects that I work on with the
minimalists and others I also have a new
podcast called the ground up show where
I speak with creative about how to build
something from nothing you can find that
at ground up show com thanks again for
watching
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you beside me
without it every little thing that you
got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach full bloom you gotta grab oh
I bet thank you son without such a
fortune
Oh
you